en réalité depuis deux siècles on est
pour ou contre napoléon le 5 mai 1821
napoléon bonaparte meur sur l'île de
sainte-hélène premier consul puis
empereur des français napoléon n'a cessé
de diviser admiré par les uns décrié par
les autres admirer comme en 1972
andré malraux voyaient en lui un symbole
de la grandeur de la france
il ya dans la peau les ont quelque chose
dont les français l'unisson rob hadley
st c'est lui qui leur a mis dans la tête
qu'il pouvait l être d admirer aussi en
1987 par jean tulard sur le plateau d'
apostrophes l'historien mettait en avant
son talent d'administrateur
ce qu'il ya d'admirables c'est que le
consulat met en place des institutions
qui sont restés jusqu'à nous à savoir le
conseil d'état la cour des comptes les
inspecteurs des finances alors
inspecteur du trésor les préfets ou
décriée comme par françois cavanna lors
de la même émission
l'écrivain dénoncer le bilan sanglant
des conquêtes napoléoniennes
si nous sommes là ce soir c'est parce
qu'il a fait je ne sais combien de
millions d'hommes
c'est pour ça ce qu'on appelle vraiment
la gloire la loire des drapeaux la
gloire des tambours d'avoir des canaux
gloire morbide pour françois cavanna
gloire nationale pour françois léotard
sur le même plateau
le ministre de la culture exprimer sa
fascination pour l'épopée napoléonienne
apple qui a toujours eu une espèce de
fierté militaire c'est toujours été
comme ça ça fait 2000 ans que ça dure
napoléon incarné ça avec deux robes et
arrière et avant d'autres mais c'est
comme ça et les français ont besoin de
cette certaines prophéties doligé la
façade à avorter en 2002 le journaliste
laurent joffrin inventer une autre
facette de napoléon la réconciliation
d'une france déchirée par la révolution
c'est le mythe du sauveur
l'idée de saisir une gloire extérieur
obtenues en temps de guerre pour
réconcilier les français
l'idée que dans une rue on accepte
l'héritage de la république mais on fait
un état fort
un état fort que choisissait de dénoncer
avec force l'ancien premier ministre
lionel jospin
auteur en 2014 du mal napoléonien
c'était un despote mais dans les termes
d'aujourd'hui ont duré un dictateur
d'une révolution née sous le signe de la
liberté on est passé au despotisme un
régime policier scénariste autoritaire
dix ans plus tôt en 2004 l'écrivain
claude ribbe rappeler une autre facette
sombre du pouvoir napoléonien il est bon
de rappeler que napoléon a rétabli
l'esclavagé la traite négrière dans les
colonies françaises
selon l'historien jean tulard il se
publie en moyenne dans le monde un
article ou un livre quotidiennement sur
napoléon
[Musique]